Welcome to "Ear Biscuits", I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at our respective
tables of adequate
and varied lighting.
We're gonna be talking about Therapy,
specifically, a discussion
that we started to have
Yeah.
Just on our own,
that we were like,
"Hey, that would be a good "Ear biscuit.""
Yeah, I think I mentioned on this show
when I decided to start
to go back to therapy
some months back
and having started to go to
therapy for the first time,
I now find myself processing
a lot about beginning that process.
And there's lots of interesting questions
that popped into my mind,
some of which I think I might need
to take to therapy, honestly
because I don't know if
they're the right questions,
I think the questions that
I'm asking and the way
that I am approaching therapy
and experiencing it as I start.
It reveals more about me
than it does about therapy.
But I kind of wanna talk
through that a little bit more
because you've been going
to therapy for a while,
not two years yet, right, maybe?
Over two years.
So for me, I've done--
I'm way ahead of you.
I should have still
You'll never catch up.
It's less than 10 sessions that I've done.
So I'm interested to hear your take on it
and also share with you
listening about my experience,
whether you've ever been to therapy,
or you've never been to therapy,
if you're thinking about going
maybe some of this discussion
can be helpful for you or encouraging
or and I don't know what it will be.
But I just feel like,
I'd like to talk about it
and explore this because
there's a lot there.
Yeah, you're just scratching the surface
and I'm just excited for you.
And this is a lot cheaper.
This is a lot cheaper,
I'm gonna be honest.
We're actually making money doing this,
in order to pay for therapy.
The couple of, as they say
on some other podcasts,
housekeeping issues--
Okay, I love housekeeping.
I do wanna acknowledge the fact that
I realized that when I say that we need
to do a podcast episode about something.
I say, or I say "We've got to record",
I say, "We've got to
record an "Ear Biscuit".
And I use the singular.
But you always say, "We've got
to record an "Ear biscuits.""
And I just kind of feel like
we need to get to the bottom of that.
Here's the problem
Because.
Its the hashtag, man.
'Cause it's like, I think as you know,
I think in terms of hashtags.
And what is the hashtag for the show?
Is it hashtag "Ear Biscuit?"
No, it's hashtag "Ear Biscuits".
That's also the name of the show.
So we're gonna record another
"Ear Biscuits", episode.
That doesn't.
I don't think I'm stepping on the hashtag
by saying an "Ear Biscuit".
No, that one episode of "Ear Biscuits"
is an "Ear Biscuit".
Exactly.
But what I'm saying is not wrong,
An "Ear Biscuits" episode.
I think I always put
Maybe--
The word episode but why are
you springing this on me?
If you're gonna
Well.
Hit me with this, you
should tell me ahead of time
because I mean,
Well,
I'm looking back on the show here.
I think the solution can be
that when I talk about it,
I say it's an "Ear Biscuit",
and when you talk about it you
say it's an "Ear Biscuits",
and that way we got both covered.
You didn't seem to
imply that was your goal
to just acknowledge that.
Well then,
I've been going to--
Oh.
I've been going to therapy
for at least two years
so I am able to arrive at
equitable solutions very quickly,
more quickly than someone
who's been in therapy
for a couple of months.
We also have,
like, this is an NPR show.
You seriously brought that up
just so you could say that
you've been to therapy
more than me?
Was that--
No.
The whole point of the "Ear Biscuits",
"Ear Biscuit" thing?
It wasn't, it just hit me
because I thought about it yesterday.
I think you changed your
mind based on what I said.
No, no, you said,
"We got to do an "Ear Biscuits", tomorrow
and I was like, "I'm gonna talk to him
"About that on an "Ear Biscuit",
because that'd be funny.
We do have a correction
that we need to make.
Now I have a group of friends
that we went to NC State with
that we stay in touch with.
We've been video chatting weekly.
A number of them, I don't know how many,
two probably, listen to "Ear
Biscuits" on the regular.
Greg, I don't know, I think.
I don't know if Greg listens.
I know that Harm
listens, okay,
And Tim, definitely listens.
And Lucas doesn't listen.
And Tim listens because
he'll start texting us
or now he puts it in the thread.
He'll just start commenting
things to us conversationally.
But he's referencing a
conversation that we've had
on "Ear Biscuits"
and he's apparently
Yeah,
Listening to it at that moment.
And he's listening the day it
comes out most of the time,
I think, because it
happens pretty, you know,
he's listened to the audio version,
so, we did a text--
which is
a tech correction, right?
Yeah, He sent us a text last
night and it was Horace grant
went to Clemson, by the way.
Oh.
So in the previous episode--
That's on you.
We're talking about the Last Dance.
Which interestingly, we also got
into a little bit of a
discussion about Jordan
because the classic
conversation about how Jordan V
and modern whatever.
Do you like how I got
into that conversation
and then made it about Hip-Hop music
and then Harm and I ended up
talking about hip hop and you guys
couldn't talk about George anymore?
As soon as you texted
that I read half of it
and then just exited
from the conversation.
I had something else going on.
Okay, which I'll tell you
about in a sec or two.
Lots of things
That's creepy.
Yes, I was talking about
the nature of NBA basketball
at the time and how the
Bulls were so unusual
and that they had these
guys like, you know,
the best player in the
world who didn't even make
his Varsity team his
sophomore year and then guys,
who went to small schools and I said,
"Scottie Pippen and Horace Grant."
What I meant to say was Scottie
Pippen and Dennis Rodman,
because Scottie Pippen
went to Central Arkansas,
and then Dennis Rodman went
to two different schools,
North Central Texas, and then
southeastern Oklahoma State.
These are not typically your
programs that are feeders
into the National Basketball Association.
So,
Clemson on the other hand.
Again, Clemson--
The great goggled one came from Clemson.
So we've cleared that up.
But it did remind me.
You know, because Tim listens.
I mean, I think it was Harm.
Oh, we're about to get corrected, again.
Somebody brought up in our
weekly scheduled video conference
that it was it was weird having friends
who have a podcast where
they talk about themselves,
and it, meaning us,
because, I don't know if
you're following along.
I'm talking about them talking about us.
Yeah.
But he made the point
that it's weird to have
conversations with us
about our personal lives
and then listen to an "Ear Biscuit."
And realize that we talked
about it--
No, you say "Ear Biscuits",
you keep it plural.
An "Ear Biscuits" episode.
And realizing that we had
recorded a show where we talked
about the same thing,
but then when we talk to them about
that aspect of our lives,
we didn't tell them that we also made it
a public conversation
that we had already had.
That hadn't come out yet.
But then after we have the
conversation with them,
they hear it again.
When it goes out to all of our audience.
And I was like, "Yeah, I guess
I don't have any friends who,
"I can't, you know what?"
I take that back.
I was gonna say, "I don't have any friends
"Who have a podcast."
But I don't really, the
personal nature of a podcast.
I think it makes it a
little weird for a friends.
So sorry, guys.
Now we're now talking
about talking about you
and talking to you on an episode
that you don't know exists
Yeah.
When we talk to you soon.
Should we give you the heads
up or just let it slide?
No, let us slide.
I see it as a little surprise.
Speaking of surprises,
the last piece of information
that we should cover
before we get started
talking about Therapy.
Yeah.
So as you know,
yesterday we were surfing
together, that was fun.
It was delightful.
I was staying up and paddling
and I was catching waves left and right.
And I was trying to
teach myself how to surf
on a regular board and I mean
to say I'm hurting today,
and I'm also very tired.
I did get up one time, as
you saw, it wasn't pretty,
but I stopped for a little bit.
I don't really wanna
talk about the surfing.
I'm just committed to getting better.
'Cause there's nothing to brag about.
So you don't wanna talk
about it.
Right.
And also, we did see a guy
there who said, "Big fan"
and I assumed he was not talking
about my surfing ability.
No, he wasn't.
I'm a little embarrassed
that he saw me at all,
to be to be honest.
But--
I'm embarrassed that he saw
you with me.
One of the things that
was happening yesterday,
it was raining unexpectedly.
It was not in the forecast.
It wasn't even on the weather
when you looked at the weather.
It was just raining but it
rained where our homes are at
and also all the way across Los Angeles.
And it was raining from
where we were surfing.
Yeah.
But one of the things that was happening
that is happening in my house as you know,
is that we've got ongoing
construction on the outdoor area.
But it's been on hold for many, many weeks
during the crisis, the pandemic,
but now things are kind of
getting somewhat back to normal
and the construction crew is out there,
social distancing, but working.
But it's still an open pit,
basically, of just dirt.
And they had to drill a hole
in the side of my garage,
which you as you know,
is below ground to get power to run
to something they're doing out there.
They drilled a hole in
the side of the foundation
into the garage.
And I think that they
and I remember seeing
the hole and thinking,
"Okay, well, we're gonna
need to seal that hole."
But of course,
I forgot about it.
Apparently they did as well.
So,
Ouch.
Yesterday while we were
enjoying ourselves and surfing,
water, and not so much
water but water and mud,
were pouring through
that hole into my garage.
And on top of that dresser
that I have in there,
that's got is basically all my stuff
that I can't fit anywhere
else in the house.
Mostly like old
electronics and like cables
that I don't know where
they go and stuff like that.
But also my old iMac is sitting there
and everything was
completely covered with mud
and somehow the way that it had cascaded
into the dresser was the old IKEA dresser.
It did filled the top drawers
and then the next layer
and then the next layer.
It had basically like
put mud in all of it.
All the drawers?
Yes.
And then it went all over the
floor and went and settled
in the front of the garage.
A bit of a mess.
And so last night, I stayed up late.
You cleaned it off?
Going through, well,
they came in cleaned up the mud.
They're cleaning up the mud today.
And they're throwing out
that old IKEA furniture
'cause once IKEA furniture
gets wet, you can just,
I mean, first of all, it's
only good for about 24 months
to begin with,
but if it gets wet--
No, you can
Its already old.
Crumple it up like a crouton
and you put it on your salad.
Okay, but, so I had to go
through the stuff to tell
the contractor like what got ruined.
Thankfully, it's not a whole lot of stuff.
There's some stuff that I just bought
some electronic stuff that I just bought
that needs to be replaced,
but it wasn't like,
stuff that I didn't have,
like, you know, backed up
and there's some old drives in there,
but it was stuff that I've got backed up
in the cloud, whatever.
So anyway, that's why I was a
little bit late this morning
because I was like, it
was tough to get moving
'cause I stayed up, just
wallowing in my own wetness
and madness and sadness.
That sucks, man.
You know,
Yeah
what?
How did that make you feel?
That's something that
therapists will say, right?
So how, how did you process this news?
What?
No, he would just say
the first thing,
how does that make you feel?
And you just leave it?
And then I would say something like,
"Well, you know, it made me think
"About how this is actually
a really small thing."
I'm actually really, really
blessed materially, you know,
and I can do with a little inconvenience
and he would be like, read,
read, read, read, read.
Don't intellectualize
it, don't rationalize it.
How does it make you feel?
So in other words,
my tendency is to try to immediately
put the positive spin on it.
That's my personality.
And he's like, "well, we can get there
"And it isn't what you said is not untrue.
"But you should process
how it makes you feel."
Because what tends to happen
is what happened this morning.
Which is I was actually
very angry about it.
I call the contractor and I'm too nice,
I was definitely as upset as
I can get at a contractor.
But still not really that upset,
but he feels bad about it.
But then like this morning,
when I was trying to meditate,
I couldn't go down there
and meditate down there
and do my workout down there.
And so I was sitting in the
living room, meditating.
And then my family
starts coming downstairs
and doing their stuff that
they do in the kitchen,
which I think is just eat.
And I started getting mad.
I started getting mad while meditating.
And then Barbara wanted
to get out of the bedroom
and she was whimpering and I was like,
"So what are the Barbara out."
And I'm sitting there the meditating man,
Yelling,
Just yelling at my family.
And it's because I didn't
stop and actually process
the way that the mud coming
through the hole made me feel.
Oh.
I held it in and then I released it
on the people who I care about most.
When is your
next Therapy appointment?
That's their work.
Next Monday.
So you didn't talk about it last night?
I did not, no, 'cause
I do every two weeks.
Okay, all right, well, let's
get into the therapy stuff
in a second.
But first, we wanna
remind you to head on over
to mythical.com where we
have just a store of stuff
that is going quick.
It's kind of like mud
coming in your garage.
It's like you don't know
when it's gonna end.
And let me tell you, the mud
is gonna stop seeping soon.
Because there's lots of stuff.
I'm gonna list these things off, may I?
Kind of underselling
our merge by saying mud.
We've got a lot of last chance items
that are the opposite of mud.
And very limited quantity.
As I'm saying this, some
of them are disappearing.
So if any of this strikes your fancy,
you better get over there.
"Strike your fancy",
is that the right word?
Pick your fancy?
Strike your fancy.
Poke your fancy?
You know I poke your fancy.
Mythical merit badges,
still got some of those,
but not many.
GMM neon sign joggers, always curious T,
one of my favorite T's.
Son wave long sleeve T.
That's a good one says,
"Good Mythical Morning",
Instagraph T for the ladies.
Know your worth coin pouch.
That's running low.
The bark dance T for the ladies
and the video club T,
another one of my favorites.
Get that thing now, get all those now,
while they last, mythical.com.
Limited.
Very limited.
For those of you watching
you can see that I've now taken to,
my mustache has gotten kind
of long I need to cut it back
but when I'm trying to
drink my drink here.
I'm having to then like use a paper towel
to, it's really annoying.
You have to dub.
I thought.
I told you about that guy
You have to dub your face.
That he was like the owner of the Texas,
whatever the football team,
the Titans, whatever they are
and he had a mustache that
went completely over both lips.
Both lips
Wow.
Covered over both lips
and then just connected
basically again with his goatee
that looked like another mustache.
Yeah.
Like it was like
two dollops of hair.
Mouthed the wall.
I don't understand that man.
Yeah, I don't understand
I don't understand
how that happens.
If you're watching this,
you also see that I'm wearing the T-shirt
from the "Thoughtful Guy" music video.
I still have this T-shirt.
I work out in it, sometimes.
It's
Oh.
Very sentimental.
You worked out this morning?
I'm thinking about doing a
little activity after this.
Of course no.
This is the first time I've put on a shirt
that has buttons in probably a month.
Let's get into Therapy, shall we?
You know, I can't remember how I described
the situation that led to
me deciding to go to therapy
but it was a long time coming.
And I'm distracted by the leaf blower.
What?
Yeah, Christy is trying
to get me go therapy
for our entire marriage,
she seems to be saying.
Well listen, you can give
me a hard time right now
'cause there's a leaf
blower right outside here
and maybe they weren't.
Here, you are the leaf blower.
I can't remember exactly
how I characterized
my decision go to therapy.
But yeah, I knew I wanted to go.
It was just kind of like,
its the little things
keep you from doing it.
Besides, well, you know,
'cause in the back of your mind,
it's like this is quite an undertaking.
I'm gonna go to a professional
and talk about myself.
And this is something that I believed in.
I was never opposed to,
everyone around me that I
care about has a positive
experience with going to therapy.
I mean, in the discussions
that we've had in this
venue, and otherwise,
I've been very encouraged
about your experience
and your level of growth
and like I've experienced
the benefits of that.
There's nothing inside of myself,
that was principally
opposed to it in any way.
Matter of fact, I would always say,
"I'm looking for a therapist."
But it was kind of a lie.
It was like, "I intend on
looking for a therapist",
is what I really should have said.
And I'm actually having a hard time
knowing what put me over the edge.
Do you remember what I
said that I was like,
I'm actually gonna do this?
It's on record.
But once I decided,
yeah I don't remember
I don't I don't recall.
But I looked through I believe
is psychology.com directory
and found some people close to
me also got recommendations.
I asked you to ask your
therapist for recommendations
'cause they don't wanna go
to the same therapist as you.
That didn't seem like the best idea.
No.
You came up dry,
but a couple of the friends
made some suggestions.
One friend made a suggestion and then
I didn't like the sound
of the therapist's name.
And I just didn't feel
like I could say that name
like have a, I don't know,
it was a distraction to me.
I'm not gonna mention
what the name is.
Well I will say that's--
It's like a weirdest thing.
This is a,
that right there is sort of an indication
of what will follow I
think in terms of the way
that you approach this right.
And I think that that's something that,
not that you should have
gone with that person.
But I do think that the way
that you think about the
things that you embark upon
is a particular way that
I think everyone will get
into what makes it
really difficult for me.
Everyone has like, there's a
difficult threshold to cross.
Well, yeah.
And it's all based.
And I think it was probably
just me putting up barriers
because maybe deep down,
I was intimidated, you
know, with the prospect
of getting into it.
You know, I have had this
growing sense that like,
there's some sort of fear with knowing
that I'm just afraid of
what I might uncover.
And I feel like maybe I'm like
with my current coping
mechanisms in the way
that I live my life.
And whatever it is that
I'm not fully exploring
or coming to grips with,
within myself or my past or both.
That I, you know, that I was
I say I want to get into it,
and I believe that it's a good thing,
but I'm just, I'm a little
afraid of what I'm afraid of,
and the unknown of it.
And so that even the smallest reason
can be reason enough to not go for it.
Which is why I find it
interesting that like,
I can't remember right now
what the trigger mechanism was,
but I think it was just
basically, Christy,
I think part of it was Christy saying,
"Will you keep saying that
you're looking for a therapist,
"But you're not actually
"And you're not really taking any steps
"And this can't, I no longer believe you."
So, like she's just
kind of calling me on it
and it was true.
Well, we would have conversations as well.
Yeah.
Because we were talking
about therapy recommending psychology.com,
talking about how therapy was
and then you would say things
like, "I listened, I'm
a real proponent of it.
"I think the people in my life
"Have really benefited from it."
But after a while, it's
like, "Okay, well."
And I've picked up enough second hand,
I'm probably good.
But I should go.
Well, but so I finally found someone
whose name was it, the other
person's name wasn't Timmy,
but it was just like, if your
therapist name is like, Timmy,
it's just like it's like,
that's just a way, you know, it's like,
I'm going to have a session with Timmy.
You know, it's like,
that's just weird.
You know, it's like--
Yes it's like, you gonna go
to get trained how to juggle by a clown
or something like that.
Right?
Right, yeah.
Well, that would be more like,
"I'm going to see my therapist honkers."
No, I can see Timmy The Clown,
I'm sure there's a Timmy
The Clown out there
that does birthday parties.
It is, you know, so I
didn't wanna be distracted
by going to see, and
Timmy is not the name,
but so, I found somebody else
who had a much more official sounding name
and you know I read about this guy
on his like Information
page on psychology.com
and then he said you can email him
just for like an initial consultation
or consultation may not have been word
but it's kinda like an
interview, both ways.
It's like, "Let's just
meet over the phone.
"Let's have a 20 minute
conversation and see
"If my skills match up
with what you're interested
"In getting into."
So I set up that call and
I went down the street.
My internet was out at
this particular time.
So which meant my phone
is very unreliable.
So then I had to drive down
and I'm sitting in the parking
lot of the grocery store
where my cell phone's
signal is very strong
so that I can have an
a cohesive conversation
with this potential therapist.
And then the 20 minute conversation
I made up my mind that I was
gonna lay everything out there
in terms of like this, you know,
instead of him, it's only 20 minutes.
So I'm just gonna lay out
there everything that I want
and everything I'm thinking about
in its concise of a way as possible.
And then also hear his response
and see if that's something
that resonates in terms you know, so,
I talked about some of the fear stuff
that I think there's
something there my past,
I talked about that a little bit.
I talked about, I gave some statistics
on my upbringing and like
being from a broken home
and like there been some things.
I gave like the bullet points
Yeah, details, background
from my past.
I talked about how my brain works now,
I talked about how, you know,
there's a low level of anxiety
that's constantly there.
I put a lot of it out there
and I was comfortable
and prepared to do that.
And we had a good conversation.
And, you know and he responded and said,
what his his specialties were,
and there was a lot of overlap there and.
But then he was like, "But
you got to call me Timmy."
And you're like, "Okay,
gotta talk to somebody else".
Well, this guy, and I'm
not gonna give his name
but he has a first name.
He has a last name and he also
has a middle initial
Oh, yeah, everybody.
In his email closing,
so that's what I call him.
Whenever I refer to him amongst my family,
I call him Tim D. Hammons.
You know, that's not his name.
I made that up on top of my
head if it didn't sound like.
I'm gonna go
Go to Tim again.
I'm gonna go, Tim is fine,
Timmy not good.
Yeah.
So, if my kids are like,
"what are you doing?"
I say, "Well, I've got
a therapy appointment
"with Tim D. Hammons."
You know, 'cause it seems official.
Yeah, I--
So I like to that too,
that the guy--
I don't, okay.
He has a--
I have an opinion.
I have an opinion about
referring to him by his full name
every time you talk to your family
about him, but,
Okay,
So, maybe I'm starting
off on the wrong foot.
So I felt like we started
off on the right foot.
In this 20 minute conversation,
there was a lot of overlap.
I was very forthright.
He was asking questions, I
talked about my family situation.
I talked about what was
healthy and what, you know,
what I felt like I wanted to explore.
And we set up the first meeting.
And man, I get really nervous.
I don't know what it is about meetings.
I mean, when we went surfing
yesterday I woke up nervous,
but
I feel like it's sometimes I misconstrue
being nervous or anxious
with being excited,
which is actually something
that he said in an early
therapy appointment.
You know, I was talking
about some situation
that I wish I wasn't getting
nervous in and he was like,
"Well, it sounds like excitement."
But I do feel like I was excited,
but I was nervous to go
in there and you know,
you sit in the waiting room,
and then there's another person
out there on their phone.
So then when he comes out,
he like, looks at me and
he doesn't say my name.
He just gives me a nod.
Because I guess he's respecting
any type of conversation
that I might have with somebody else there
like if I were to say my name
or something like you know,
he must respect my boundaries,
however strict they may be.
So he comes out and he gives
me a nod and I follow him.
We haven't even spoken.
And I was like, "I respect
that, but it's still a little,
"It puts me on, I'm on edge, right?"
And I go in the room,
and there's the couch.
There's an actual couch.
Now, it's not a chaise lounge.
It's not like a thing where it's like,
well,
You don't lay down?
I could lay down on this couch.
But it's not like a chaise lounge.
You really can't do anything
but lay down, right?
So it's like the cartoon therapist.
Forces it
Every movie, yeah.
Every movie.
This is like a reasonably sized sectional.
But like my brains going
a million miles an hour.
I'm like, should I lay down?
Should I take off my shoes?
Should I, should, you know, it's like.
So I sit there, like a
normal person on a couch.
And we start a conversation.
He's sitting in like a special,
a desk chair that's borderline
or recliner, I mean,
I guess if your job is
sitting and listening,
you better have a good chair.
I think it had a swivel to it.
These are other things I'm
thinking in my first appointment.
I'm looking at what he's got on the wall.
I'm looking at the bookshelf behind him
'cause as he's talking,
which isn't often by the way,
I can look past him and I
can read some of the books
that he's been reading and
learn something about him.
How to do therapy for Dummies.
Yeah,
if you see that behind
your guy or your girl
you didn't do that.
I don't ask him to pull it off the shelf
and let's just read straight from it.
Okay, so let me get in here.
Get in here, 'cause--
You said the stage about
like your first impression
and like what's going through
your mind when you walk in.
So and I'll tell a little
bit about my story now,
I do wanna just do a slight sidebar.
Because, you know, interestingly
after we kind of shared
our last year story,
and for those of you who didn't hear that,
that was when we kind of talked
about our Christian background,
growing up, working as missionaries,
and then how we both sort of
changed the way that we think
and feel about all that
and no longer consider
ourselves Christians.
Obviously, going public with that,
was a little bit of a lightning rod,
amongst the people who
listen to our podcasts
and just the sort of the
Christian media world
in some ways, right.
And a lot of people talked about it.
Well, one of the things
that I saw was a fair amount
of criticism about how,
you know, of course we get the criticism
about how we've gone all LA,
but one of the things that
comes along with that is,
you guys are basically replaced
God with therapy, right?
And in doing so you've
kind of replaced God
with yourself, right?
Because some people's
perspective on therapy
is that it's so self
absorbed and self focused
and people who go to therapy
and are constantly trying
to figure out what they feel
and what they think and
process through these things
could become self absorbed assholes,
which I think is kind
of missing the point.
But one of the things that
Jessie and I have talked about
is that and as we said
in this in the last years
is we've benefited in a lot of ways
from being a part of a
religious community, right.
Being a part of a spiritual community.
There's a lot of growth that
took place in that community.
And while we have our issues
with a lot of the views
and some of the foundational
propositions of Christianity
at this point,
it was really instrumental in us growing
into the kind of people
that we are, right?
Absolutely.
But one of the interesting things
that I sort of picked up on
and this may not be as
much the case anymore,
it may have been a little
bit more like a 90s,
early 2000s kind of thing.
But in both me and Jessie's experience,
there was very much a one size-fits-all
sort of program.
It was basically like, if you're a man,
this is the kind of
man that you should be.
This is what being a man is about, right?
If you're a woman it's a
very different program.
This is what being a woman is,
and I, as a 40 year old man had never,
ever dealt with a lot of stuff
that was going on inside my
head and my heart, right.
Because I knew how to fall in line
and I knew what the program
for me as a man was,
but, which was based on some things
that I no longer agree with.
But, it just kind of struck me
that when I started going to therapy,
the level of which I was actually dealing
with the specifics of my background,
my family of origin and my personality
was kind of revolutionary.
And I'm not saying that
that doesn't happen in
spiritual communities,
and that doesn't happen in
the Christian community.
But it didn't happen in the communities
that I was a part of, right.
It really took taking that next
step in going into something
where I was gonna deal with
myself in my own shit, right.
And I think that you
having seen me do that,
your wife do that, my wife to that,
you knew that this wasn't gonna be like
going to a men's conference
where it might get really personal,
and it might get really real,
but you're gonna kind of walk away
with some marching orders,
that everybody dude who's
there is gonna walk away with,
but you probably are
not gonna deal directly
with some personal growth
or kind of directly addressing
some, and not again,
this is probably happening
in some churches or whatever,
but it just didn't happen
for us.
Right.
But I think that you knew that like,
"Oh man, I know what this
process is going to entail,
"And it's gonna entail getting
in touch with my past."
And for you, that is very specific.
It's more of a typical,
this person needs to be in
therapy kind of past right?
You know, your dad left,
raised by single mom,
okay,
Right.
Okay, yeah, you should
be in therapy, right.
Now for me, somebody who
came from a stable home,
my parents are still together.
In my mind, I had never and the fact
is that when it comes to like trauma
I don't have a lot of trauma
everybody's got trauma
and some people want to minimize,
not trying to minimize my own situation.
But I don't have this profile
that's just like "You need help", right.
But it was my wife,
seeing the way that I was
processing all the stuff,
all the pressure that we
had sort of put on top
of us over the years.
And the fact that we're
trying to lead this company
and pursue these dreams,
and it's just like,
we were under a lot of pressure
on a really regular basis--
Not to mention
the fact that you started to go blind.
Yeah, and it was coming out sideways,
both in the way that I
would kind of blow up,
but also in the way that I
was suffering physically.
And the most acute symptom
being the I don't even know
what it's called anymore,
but basically, my retina was,
I got some fluid behind my eye
and it's a stress related condition
that can cause temporary
blindness, pretty scary.
So you literally couldn't
see out of one eye?
Well, it could, it was very blurry,
like the center of the field of vision.
Yeah--
For me
it was these acute symptoms
that kind of sent me over the edge.
But I just wanted
to cover that because,
Yeah.
You know, that little, that former self
is always sitting there on my shoulder
kind of telling me the
way you sound right now.
And I know that people
may be turned off by
and I want to,
and not to mention the fact
that there's a stigma associated with it,
where it's like,
you've got to have something
specifically acutely wrong.
You've got to have
something in your background
that warrants it.
But you know, you don't
have to have any condition
to start working out, right.
You don't have to have a physical ailment
in order to begin working out.
Well, exercising has been
shown to make your life better
and longer and all kinds of ways, right.
And I think that in going to the doctor
on a regular basis is a good idea.
And I think that everyone has
something in their personality
that has been constructed
as a defense mechanism
based on their background,
and the stuff that they've been through.
And everybody's been through something.
And so I just, you know,
I think that anyone is a candidate for it
and can benefit from it
And I believe that
but for the longest time,
I didn't believe that because I was never,
no one ever said it.
But, you know, my entire
experience of growing up
was in the church.
Well, I wanna limit this
to my specific experience
and not talk about the church in general.
my specific
Yeah.
Experience and limited to that
was I got the impression by
reading between the lines,
that as I cultivated my
relationship with God,
and that, you know, Jesus
can meet all of our needs.
And he does that, yes,
he does that through all types of ways
and through interactions with people
as included in that,
including professionals.
But I always thought of it.
We talked about counseling,
you might need counseling,
you might need couples counseling,
you know, you might need some
help walking through this.
And its is very, in a
spiritual environment.
But therapy was something for people
who had a diagnosable problem
or something that was extremely serious
that then you gotta go to another level.
And I just thought that like,
nothing in my life is bad
enough for that, for therapy.
You know, I can handle
everything with counseling
and through the cultivation
of my spirituality
and these other ways.
But now I'm not presenting an either-or,
you can absolutely benefit
from both at the same time.
In the conversations that
we've had with our friends,
You know, we've seen that
just to go back to Tim,
not the fake name of my therapist,
but our friend who knew that Horace Grant
was from Clemson.
Right.
Who's a pastor, now.
But so moving on from that
when I started therapy,
I was ready to go in,
I was ready to explore things.
Matter of fact, I started to have ideas
of what I wanted to go into.
And so he would start off
with "So how are you doing?
"How's your day?
"How's your week?"
It's where he would start
and then I would be like,
"Okay, I have an idea
of where I wanna go."
There's two different things,
I have this immediate need
of we're planning this big vacation
with my extended family like
Christy side of the family.
We're gonna go to Disney World, but like,
I'm feeling a lot of anxiety
associated with that.
And I want to deal with
that in a healthy way.
And I don't wanna be
the one to screw that up
for my entire extended family
'cause this is a big deal.
But, and that's like an immediate need.
But then I got this, the
deeper stuff that I know
I wanna get into about like my past
and how I view myself
and how there's so much
like my inner critic is so strong,
and I feel like I suffer from that.
And so in the first two sessions
I talked about both of those two things.
Interestingly enough,
we were going through
having put out the lost years podcasts,
and I chose not to bring any of that up
because it was like
that's a whole other thing
I'm not ready to get into
even though it was something
that I was very much
dealing with at the time.
You know, so and like he didn't
even really have an inkling
that was going on because
I never brought it up.
Because in my mind,
I had prioritize these other
things I wanted to talk about
and get into.
And then, so even once I
started to get into those things
Half of my mind is trying to figure out
how does this work?
And how does he work specifically?
And how do I work?
So it wasn't just having a conversation,
but it was analyzing everything
to figure out the system, you know?
So it'd be like, okay,
he'll ask me a general question,
and then I dictate what
I wanna talk about.
And then if I make a statement,
if I get to a point
where I'm done talking,
then he'll ask another
clarifying question about it.
And I'll need to think about
it for a second and answer.
And then when I'm done with that,
and just let me finish
what I observed as a system
and then at that point,
I would observe sometimes
I would finish talking and
he wouldn't ask anything.
He wouldn't say anything.
He would just be quiet.
And that's when it got a little weird
because I'm immediately feeling like,
"Okay, I'm done."
I put something out there.
He's quiet, am I supposed to talk now?
Or you supposed to talk?
It's like that scene in
"Star Wars" where he's like,
"Are you gonna talk now?
"Or am I gonna talk?"
You know, and so I brought so much
my brain was so hot in
going into the situation.
And I, then that's how it
went for the first few.
It was like two different
levels of conversation
going on in my own mind.
Yeah, so I mean, we talked
about this a little bit,
but you're an enneagram one.
You don't have to know
what the enneagram is.
And we haven't done an
episode about it yet.
But you're a perfectionist, right?
So, you're driving sort of
guiding principle in life
is you wanna make sure that
you're doing things right.
for me--
The best possible way.
Which is a performer.
So I wanna make sure that I'm doing things
not necessarily right,
but I wanna be the best
at whatever it is, right.
I wanna perform.
And those are actually pretty similar,
they manifest themselves
in pretty similar ways,
especially when you encounter
anyone else in life, right?
And so me and you tend
to be super self aware,
and we analyze everything.
And we're thinking about
things almost like a filmmaker,
you know, stepping back
and observing the way
things that are happening.
And what that's doing is it's, again,
this is really just a figurative
way of talking about it,
but you're kind of
getting out of your heart
and getting out of your feelings
and you're getting into your head
and you're moving into
this analytical place
where there's not a lot of progress,
there's not a lot actual work
that happens once you step out
and you get it especially
when it gets so analytical
that you're actually thinking
only about the process
that's happening between
you and that person.
But it's the only natural
response for most people.
Like, for me, the thing
that took me forever
and I still have a tendency to do this.
Because I'm a performer,
sometimes my therapy appointment
will come up and I'm like,
"Oh man, I don't have
anything for him today."
You know, I don't have
anything for him today, right?
Like, it isn't going to be worth his time
to spend time with me today.
Because I'm not gonna bring it you know,
I've got to perform for this guy.
And that may take the
form of very early on
and like some of the initial things,
it was, "All right I kind of want
"To let this guy know that",
and again, this wasn't
a conscious process,
but it was like, "I kind
of want to let this guy
"know that I'm not crazy, okay.
"It's like alright, let's
get that out of the way.
"I'm not crazy.
"You know, I'm a stable person.
I'm a stable genius."
You know, I kind of understand
what's happening here.
I know what you're trying to do,
and I am basically saying,
"Hey, I'm gonna be a
good partner in this,"
like, "I'm gonna give you what you need,"
which is, you just tell me
how I'm supposed to go about this.
And I'll do a good job
at it like, you know,
show me the steps to perform
because as soon as I understand that,
I'll lock in and I'll be
your best patient ever.
Again, not a conscious process.
that's how I process it.
I find myself
whenever like I'm racking my brain
to figure out what it
is I wanna talk about
before I go in there.
And I don't feel good.
I feel horrible until I
can answer that question.
And just to skip ahead a little bit.
Like we went from week to week
'cause it was a trial thing.
And it was, I said, let's do every week
and then with the pandemic
and the isolation,
things went flux and we didn't schedule
and then it was like let's
just do every other week.
And then it got to a
point where I was like,
ironically, I was having
the most difficult time,
you know as you know, this past week
has been extremely difficult.
This is, you know, when I did
the live stream with Britain,
I shared some of this there
too, because it you know,
with what Christy is going through
and her level of anxiety,
me caring for her,
and it's been very
difficult for both of us.
And you know, we've talked
about all this but ironically,
I made an active decision not to schedule
a therapy appointment,
because I just felt like,
I don't even know the reason it was like,
now that I'm really into this thing,
and we had talked about it
when it wasn't as acute.
I had had a meeting or
two with him remotely
and we had discussed it
because I'd made up my mind
I wanted to discuss it.
And then I found myself
canceling the appointment,
and I haven't gone.
We haven't met in a couple of weeks,
and now there is no
standing appointment at all.
I found it so interesting
how when I'm going
through the toughest time,
I made a decision in spite of myself
to not go at all it's like, and--
Here's the ironic thing, right.
The ironic thing is
that you're so concerned
about doing it wrong,
that you know what, you're
actually doing it wrong.
Yeah, and even
when I would go--
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
'Cause it's like, again,
I think that it's, again it comes
from a slightly different place,
but the application is often the same
and that is, the thing
is I have stopped doing.
And this would be my advice for you.
Is I've stopped thinking
about the appointment
before the appointment is happening.
I stopped thinking about what
am I gonna bring tonight?
Like, what are my bullet points?
This isn't like sixth grade
when I was calling my girlfriend
and I had to have a list
of things to talk about.
So I wouldn't run out, right?
This is about getting in
touch with what I'm feeling.
And ironically, as well, you know,
when you talk about what
you're going through,
we obviously we've been talking a lot
about what you've been going through
and going with going through with Christy.
In my last appointment,
and again, I've kind of
made this habit of like,
"I'm not gonna think about this.
"I'm not going in with any agenda
"Even though it is up to me, right?"
He's gonna say, "How you doing?"
So he was like, "how you doing?"
And I was like "I don't know, I think,
"I mean, I'm doing okay."
And then I'll just kind
of just start talking
about things that are going on.
And you know, the thing
that he's really good
at is picking up on super empathetic
and to kind of get to things
that I don't even know
that I'm feeling.
But basically what our appointment became,
our conversation became about was the fact
that I was having a lot of anxiety
about what was happening
with you and Christy.
Like that, we were talking about it
and I'm trying to figure out,
what can I do about this, right?
Like, what can I say
to help you and Christy
during this time?
Jessie and I are talking about it a lot.
And it's like I started realizing
that I was having all this anxiety
about your situation.
But, if I had just
thought about my agenda,
I would have never got there.
What I would have done
is I would have gone in
and I would have thought,
"Well, the thing that I
need to talk about right now
"Is this issue that I'm
having at work or whatever."
But when I go in without an agenda,
and I really just try
to just start talking
about whatever it is
that might be happening,
even sometimes it's just like,
catching up with a friend, right?
'Cause we're friends now.
So it might just be like,
"Oh, we did something cool.
"We went surfing today, I
searched for the dolphin,
"whatever it might be",
and then that will lead
into something else.
But that's been the most
helpful thing for me
is getting past the agenda
and the planning or the prioritizing.
Thinking that you've got
to put this ahead of this,
I got to deal with this
before I get to this.
Is not organizing a garage, right.
And that's your tendency is gonna be,
I got to approach this
the way I would approach
washing dishes.
Well, let me--
You know what I'm saying?
I appreciate that.
Let me just respond to that
'cause there's a lot in there.
I think, first of all, it's very touching
for me to hear that you
talked about my situation
in your therapy, and I feel
like that means a lot to me.
And I think, you know, I feel
like I reaped the benefits
of that in terms of the conversations
that we've had with, you know,
at this point, the light
at the end of the tunnel
is very bright like, you know, Christy's
in a very good place and
I'm in a very good place,
but when it was at the darkest moments,
and we were having those conversations,
I couldn't have done without it.
So I wanna thank you for that.
And I also wanna thank the other friends
like the friends that we
talked about at the top
of this episode, you know,
every week having that touch point
where it's like we can just hang out
and like we're asking
how everybody's doing.
And that's been extremely helpful.
And I've told them that
but I just, you know,
for those of them that are listening,
I wanna thank them specifically now
because it was extremely helpful.
And I am seeing that if
I would have just gotten
out of my own way,
I could have also benefited
from having my standing
therapy appointment
that if I would have made it standing
and not just made it a
question mark every time.
So then back to this conversation,
I just feel like that's very helpful.
And it's interesting
because in the conversations
that I have with him at a certain point,
I'm like, "Okay, this is an
hour, I'm at the 45 minute mark,
and I feel like I've talked about
I've gotten my marching orders."
And I will find myself saying things like
I've said this on a number of sessions,
about 45 minutes in, I'll be like,
I've got a practical plan
that addresses my concern
or complaint that I decided to bring up
as part of my curriculum, right.
And what I'll say is,
I'll say "That's helpful."
So it's like, it's basically me saying,
"I got what I came for,
I got my money's worth,"
you know, or however, I'm thinking about,
I would say,
Yeah.
That's very helpful.
But then I would feel like,
"Okay, but it's also an assignment
"Because now I need to apply this plan
"So that next time we
talk in a week or two
"Whenever the standing appointment is
"That I gotta show that I've applied this
"Like as if there was a test."
I'm realizing that, you know,
because at one point
we talked about like doing
some work where we're talking
about the inner critic, and he said,
"You know, what a creative
exercise you can do
"Is you can start to
create a character profile
"For this voice of an
inner critic in your mind."
You know, you might see
him as, you run a company,
that is your life.
And your inner critic
is the head of security.
And he might say, his name is
Bob and Bob comes up to you,
and he's very zealous.
And he's like,
"Well, you know, we've
got to put armed guards
"At every door of the facility,"
and then you're like, "Bob,
I appreciate the sentiment,
"But we're not gonna put
armed guards at every door.
"But what we are gonna do is this."
And you put Bob in his place.
Because he's just your head of security.
He's not running your company.
But he's like you can come
up with any way you want.
And so I was like,
"Oh man now, I just got
a homework assignment."
And I'm talking to Christy
and Lilly about this ever.
I'm like, and now here it is.
It's been a week and I'm
talking to him in another week.
I'm halfway there.
And I haven't, I was gonna journal down
my character description of
what my inner critic looked like
I was like, and I asked
Christy and Lily I was like,
"Is this what you mean by doing the work?"
'Cause this is like literal homework.
And now that I've gone,
I'm over halfway there and I
haven't done my assignment,
I'm like, now I'm all
up in arms about that.
And then we did have a session
and I was able to talk
about my inner critic
but I kind of crammed to do this homework
and like, it kind of
rubbed me the wrong way.
Yeah, well, I mean, I haven't had
and this may be my therapist
insight into me as a performer.
I haven't really had any
specific assignments,
he has suggested a couple of
things that might be like,
you know, I think it would be
helpful to write that down.
Or, you know, but the thing
that I've kind of gotten into
the habit of is, you know,
we kind of go through it, the
end, we kind of go through,
he's always says, "What
stands out for you tonight?"
You know, and that's my cue to figure out
what the big the big takeaways are.
And then I went for a long
time having these like,
really what I consider to
be significant insights,
and then I would sort of
remember them again, next time.
And then now if there's
a significant insight
I do try to like okay,
take 10 minutes.
Yeah.
And journal about it,
just to kind of remember it
to kind of put a stake in the ground.
But yeah,
since that assignment you had been back?
Yeah, I went back once and
he didn't grill me on it.
I told him, I did do it.
And I did benefit from it.
And like--
What did you talk about?
Did you talk about the
way that you thought
about the assignment?
No.
And and the thing that
Christy and Lily told me,
as I like, told them
about how I approach it,
they say things like,
"He's there for you."
You seem to be talking
like you're there for him.
And--
Right.
Which is kind of what we're saying.
And they said, "You should
talk to him about that."
And I was like,
"Okay, that's--
Well, it's funny,
because when--
I was like,
"Now you've given me an assignment."
So my therapist and I
have talked about you
and you going into therapy, right.
I talked to him about everything.
So and talking with him
about your initial reservations
that you've explained to me,
it got us talking about the
way that we talked about,
we talked to each other and the way
that I perceive it.
Yeah.
And I hope the way that I
perceive it as a performance,
and I told him, I was
like, sometimes, you know,
for the longest time, I was like,
"What do I have for him?
Yeah.
And so that became like,
getting to that level of specificity
and laying it all out there.
And if you push you started realizing
is that you just got
all these little things
that you're hiding not
only from your therapist
for yourself.
Yeah,
And it's just like you're playing
this little game of like, hide the ball.
And you got to take the
cuffs off the balls, man,
you got to put your balls on the table.
But I mean, I'm adjusting
how I'm looking at it,
because I realized in a number of ways
that I'm looking at it wrong
and I, you know, I do realize going back
to how we perceive therapy,
I think the thing that I'm
bringing to it is, you know,
the only point of reference
that I have directly
is counseling and accountability groups.
Now, in in our church youth group,
and definitely in college,
we would set up these accountability
groups where it's like,
hey, you have a small group,
maybe it's just one other person,
that you trust, and that
you want to share things
that you wanna improve in your life,
it could be spiritual in nature,
it could be practical in nature.
But then you've got someone
who will hold you accountable
when you get together.
The main point of the meeting
is for them to ask you,
'cause you've given them permission.
It's kind of like a personal trainer.
Especially in these times
where you're not with
the personal trainer,
and you're like have you done
your exercises this week?
Well, it could be that for anything
can be like,
Yeah,
Did you meet this goal or that goal?
Or did you not participate
in this activity
that you promised you weren't gonna do?
Kind of thing.
And most accountability
groups between men
it would be, "did you
look at porn this week?"
Right and be very aggressive about that.
And the ultimate accountability hack,
this is the thing that I never
really understood until later
and I think a lot of people were operating
under this principle,
the ultimate accountability
hack is just lying
I never lie.
You lie to cover
accountability porn?.
No, no, no, no,
I'm saying that, no I didn't lie.
But I figured out later
that some of the people,
They were hacking
the system.
the system, they were lying.
They were hacking more than the system,
they were hacking the lumber.
I've never actually heard
that as a euphemism,
but I think I--
Well I think it's whack
the lumber.
Okay, well--
To be specific.
I feel like and then when
you go to counseling,
if you have a problem, and you like
when I would meet with my pastor,
it'll be like, "I'm dealing with this."
It was a positive experience.
But I think in my mind,
there was a negative aspect to it,
that I now apply to therapy
and that is, I always
assumed there was a judgment.
You know, it's like--
It's like
going to confession.
It's like going to confession
if you're Catholic,
which we never were,
but yeah, so it's like,
"Hey, I'm sharing this."
And then the response
that you get from the authority figure is,
"Well, this is the
proper belief or action,
"Or, and this is how
you're falling short."
"But you know what?
"Here's the strength,
"And here's the path to get
back on the right track."
But there's an implied
judgment there, right?
That the thing with therapy
that I just can't seem to let sink in
is that it's a judgment free zone.
There's been plenty of things
that I put out even on that
first 20 minute phone call.
You know, he asked me
some pointed questions
about how do I deal with stress?
And stuff like that.
And how I deal with the
things that I was confessing?
I felt like I approached
it like a confessional.
And I just felt like I've
confessed more things
that like and then would cringe.
It's like, yeah,
this is expecting there to be
some implied unspoken judgment
that then led to this is
what you do to correct that.
Yeah.
But that's not what therapy is.
Therapy is not--
No,
but we're looking for our
marching orders, I mean.
But there's also a judgment,
I think anticipating--
Yeah.
A judgment and then a correction,
which the correction
is the marching orders.
There's a competing aspect
I think that's very related.
It's very related to I think
it's probably pretty typical,
but I think it's it was
reinforced by our background,
because when you went to talk to someone
who was in some sort
of spiritual authority
over you, that's what
you were looking for,
you were looking for--
Correction.
What is the authoritative thing
that I'm supposed to
submit to and do right now?
And, with that there's some personalities
that just lock onto that like for somebody
who is a perfectionist,
you lock on to the instructions.
For someone who is a performer,
we lock on to the instructions as well
because it fulfills that need.
And I think the thing
that's been so difficult
is you start realizing
that so many of your issues
kind of relate to that
orienting principle in life,
the thing the way that you
approach everything, right,
which is why the enneagram is very helpful
because it helps you understand
that sort of main driver.
And then you start realizing
that everything that I do,
the way that I behave in my relationships,
the way that I behave
in my job and the things
that I'm trying to do long term,
they're all being filtered through that.
And so when you're therapy,
because it's inevitable,
because it's another relationship, right?
It's just another relationship
it's another thing that you do.
Your tendency is always
going to be to approach
it in exactly the same way.
I mean, I'm not saying, I've fixed this,
the only thing that I've
done is it hit me real hard.
That, "Oh, you're just applying
the same old rat approach
"To this as well."
You've put the Rhett's
spin on this relationship.
But this the whole idea,
this relationship is to break that down.
And you know, and I think
that you're so early
in the process right now that you applying
that pressure to yourself
is actually keeping you
from getting into the process
and having the appointment,
you know,
Yeah, I don't think
I just, it's like my entire being,
just can't believe that he's
there to help me explore
and gain insight into
myself without judgment.
I haven't gotten there yet.
So I don't know if it's probably
something to talk about,
you know, but again,
I'm gonna send an email and say,
"Hey, let's get back on track,"
you know, and then kind of give
them some of the background.
Or maybe I'll talk about that.
A lot of this stuff I think I'll talk
about in the next time I talked to him
and then set the groundwork
for "Hey, I do wanna make
this sustaining appointment.
"I don't want there to be a question mark,
"Week to week where I have
to make an active decision
"and can just
"Bow out of the thing."
Yeah.
And then just
talk about some of these issues with him.
And like half insights
that have gotten, you know,
see how he responds to that.
But, you know,
it's 'cause like you said,
it is a relationship with a person
but it's a professional
relationship that then, you know,
like I just I need therapy
to reorient my expectations,
my approach, how I do this thing.
But again, am I falling back into the trap
even as I talk I was like,
Okay,
Constantly.
I haven't been doing it right.
I'm gonna talk to him
about how I do it right.
Oh, dude, it's the--
I'm doing right now.
One of the reasons that
and we should definitely talk about
do at least an episode on meditation
because I think that the thing
that matters mindfulness meditation
or just a simple like focusing
on the breath meditation does
is it reveals sort of the pattern
and nature of your thoughts.
And for me, and I assume this
is the case for many people
and probably also for you like for me,
it's I can't, I'm such a thrill.
I'm such a performer,
that I cannot sit down
and meditate without picturing
someone watching me meditate.
Like, I'm always doing something
for an audience, right?
And then in the moment
that I have an insight,
while meditating, I'm thinking
about the conversation
that I'm going to have in the future
with someone to tell
them about this insight,
so that they will think better of me.
But then here's the thing,
meditation brings these
things out in their ugliness
and shows them to me,
it shows that pattern.
It's like, you start realizing that,
oh, you're getting into that thing again
where you can't just be in the present,
you're thinking about the past,
you're thinking about the future,
you're applying these principles.
And then in every single
thing that you do,
like, for me, like is
this constantly, like,
I'm gonna have to be resistant
to not talk to my therapist
about this "Ear Biscuit"
in a way that he's like,
"Hey, you know, those conversations
"That Lincoln I had about
Therapy or whatever,"
like talking about it in
a way that positions me
as the as the protagonist,
right as the star.
Like, that's my issue.
And so I just have to constantly
but at least I'm thinking about it right?
At least there's a there's an awareness.
But for the longest time it was just like,
my way of being and I
didn't even understand
the destructive nature of it.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, you're gonna like the way
that you think about.
I'll live through it.
The way that you think about it.
The way that you think about
the way that you think about it
will be subject to the way
that you think about it.
Okay.
And you got to think about that man.
All right, that was funny.
I guess it is, maybe--
It's also true.
It's true.
Okay.
Again, I don't in conclusion,
I have no conclusion for anyone else.
So, as with earlier "Biscuits",
take from it what you
want take nothing from it.
But I appreciate the conversation.
And again, it's helpful for me and
that's plenty.
Yes, well, I guess I'll give a wreck now.
Yeah, so it is your turn to give a wreck.
Go for it.
Thank you to whoever
shared this video with me.
And actually several of
you shared this video
there was a video by a guy
a YouTuber named Beau Miles,
who is an Australian university professor
and sort of adventurer
who has a YouTube channel that
he doesn't upload very often,
but mostly 'cause the videos
that he makes take a lot of effort,
they're very artistic vlogs
and vlog is probably not the best word.
But he did a video called "The Human Bean"
where he ate his body weight
in beans, canned beans,
and it took him 40 days.
Docs his series.
Yeah,
he documents his process in a very,
I mean he's a funny guy.
He's funny, but he's
also very introspective
and thoughtful and it was just I got
into his YouTube channel and, you know,
he took a trip he kayaked
from Australia to Tasmania
and made like a six part series.
Just some very special YouTube content
that it's not at all really
trying to play the game
to get clicks.
It's just like, "This
dude's just living a life
"Down there in Australia,
"And has found a really
compelling way to capture it."
And it's been you got me to watch it,
and it's been a source
of inspiration for us.
Yeah.
Creatively, so.
I agree with that--
Beau Miles,
and that's Beau spell like B-E-A-U.
Beautiful, Beau Miles.
That's a good name for
I'm not saying it's beautiful,
but that's just how you
spell his name.
Therapists.
All right, hashtag "Ear Biscuits".
We'll speak at you next week.
I just lost Rhett because my iPad died.
I don't know if he's still talking to you.
But I'm gonna choose to
shut down this episode.
So at least we have that from one of us.
Very interested in what
Rhett's on right now
but I have lost contact with
him at the perfect moment.
Hashtag "Ear Biscuits".
We'll talk at you next week.
Thanks for all the love and support
that you've given to me and Christy.
And it means a lot.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.